la france est le troisième pays qui émet
le moins de co2 pour sa production
d'électricité
objectif de l'état pour les années qui
viennent accompagner la transition
écologique et énergétique et des sites
émetteurs de co2 appartenant à la
filière mines et métallurgie
dans ce cadre la ministre délégué chargé
de l'industrie s'est rendu ce jeudi 20
mai sur le site dit on sen à bonnières
sur seine
au programme visites et nouvelle
signature du contrat stratégique et deux
filières dans le but de réduire
l'empreinte carbone
on a une feuille de route qui va d'abord
être technologie par technologies et
processus par processus est ensuite site
par site pour définir comment on va
atteindre une réduction significative de
notre empreinte carbone sur cette
industrie
ils t'ont scène du groupe riva a
présenté son site et le processus de
fabrication
l'entreprise de sidérurgie de 250
salariés produit 400 mille tonnes de
ronds à béton par an elle est déjà
avancé sur le sujet c'est ce qu'on fait
déjà donc il ya ce qu'on fait déjà on
est on recycle majorité de la ferraille
française donc de toute façon on n'en
voit pas notre ferraille à l'autre bout
du monde la visite était l'occasion
d'aborder d'autres sujets notamment les
difficultés à recruter dans la filière
on en avait beaucoup de chutes à
recruter aujourd'hui on avait des
métiers vraiment que tu es en tension
est majoritairement les métiers de la
maintenance
la ministre a bien les produits en
disant que effectivement c'était une
réalité et que changer plutôt aux
industriels qu'ils n'avaient pas ce pour
ces problèmes là et aujourd'hui
l'industrie peine à recruter
c'est souvent une des premières
questions qui nous remontent lorsqu'on
visite des sites
ce travail de décarbonation dans la
filière mines et métallurgie a déjà été
opéré dans les filières de la chimie ou
encore du ciment